President Biden being accused of bad
Optics to say the least while boasting
about the economy the president enjoined
some ice cream while bragging that he is
doing a good job that's despite
inflation running at a 40-year high and
the issue topping the list of voter
concerns
what are you concerned about the
strength of the dollar right now
I'm not concerned about the transmission
Valor I'm concerned about the rest of
the world
does that make sense
yes our economy is strong as hell
inflation is worldwide it's worse off
everyone else than it is in the United
States but the American people feel
differently nearly 78 percent think the
economy is in bad shape under Biden and
71 percent of people say their family
has had to cut back just to afford the
Necessities the New York Post
highlighting the pain your 401K plans
are feeling 2.1 trillion dollars have
been wiped this year all that bad news
is dragging Democrats down on the
campaign Trail but Pete bootage thinks
the problem is that the president he has
just been too successful
there have been so many accomplishments
right the chips act that's bringing
manufacturing back to the United States
uh The Pact act getting veterans the
benefits they deserve of course the
infrastructure Bill the inflation
reduction act on top of that American
Rescue plan uh you know in some ways
having achieved so much legislatively
makes it hard to talk about it all at
once because there are just so many
accomplishments judge I imagine that the
chief of staff Ron Clane probably got
some calls after that viral video of the
ice cream saying this is not helping our
situation you know Dana I couldn't help
but think about Marie Antoinette like
let them eat cake you know I'm eating my
ice cream but you know the crazy part
about this whole thing is as the
president and Buddha judge talk about
how great the economy is your average
American is sitting there trying to
figure out whether they buy chicken this
week or eggs this week or meet this week
and you know now the gas is going back
up how much do they have to plan for now
that the winter is coming how much do
they have to plan to heat their house
and I I just find it so incredible that
it's so easy to say our economy is
strong as hell and inflation is not a
problem and Buddha jet says thank
goodness for the American Rescue plan
which it's a general consensus among
economists that it has contributed to
inflation but I have this list of G20
countries he says it's the rest of the
world that's suffering it's not the rest
of the world it's like China is doing
better Japan's doing better Saudi Arabia
is doing better Switzerland France South
Korea Indonesia they don't even know the
facts and yet they're trying to convince
the American people that things are
better you're just too stupid to get it
Jessica I have a theory
um and since you are a mom of a young
one you don't have school-aged children
yet but let me run this Theory by you in
August the president had ticked up a
little bit in approval gas prices were
coming down in September that got
reversed and in October then you see the
inflation numbers are down but that poll
out of the New York Times today saying
that Independent Women they've had this
huge swing from Biden to Republicans and
one of my my theory is that one of the
things that very much focused the mind
was the beginning of school and how
expensive it is to get your kids back to
school so it's all the shopping that you
have to do school fees Sports fees the
uniforms and everything cost a lot more
and that it began to feel overwhelming
to women in America that the economy was
just not going to get better under Biden
I like it that's a theory it sounds good
to me um anything to explain a swing of
that level I was totally floored not
only did women go to a split of 47-47
but the Independent Women the Democrats
were up 14 points and now the GOP has an
18-point edge right that's astronomical
especially when you think about how
dependent the Democratic party is on the
sport of women especially
college-educated women where they still
have an edge but much much smaller
people are settling back to regular life
we've had a month and a half being back
at school people are back to work in
offices now they're commuting they're
having to fill up their gas tanks that's
a lot more activities think about
vacation thanksgiving's gonna coming up
how much will it cost to go visit family
then the holidays come presents Etc so
all of that is top of mind and when you
look at the New York Times Siena poll
which I don't know if it you know
pretends that this will be a trend that
now the GOP will be up three four points
excuse me but between the economy and
inflation together no other issue seems
to matter in America and Public Safety
is down there but abortion's down at
Five Points and we were talking about
the Harvard Harvard Harris poll last
night on the big midterm show that
showed that people don't think that
Democrats are talking about anything but
January 6th and women's rights and that
spells absolute disaster from the
midterm tonight uh Jesse take a listen
to this is how the Biden team they got
sent out to try to spin this over the
weekend I think we have this call for
watch here
the many parts of the bill will start to
take effect next year for example there
are tax credits for energy to help
people weatherize their homes and also
bring down other forms of energy costs
we are doing all we can to ease
inflationary pressures and we see
results it's going to take some time for
those results to get into the pricing
because we'd like to see that happen a
whole lot faster elements of the
inflation reduction act aren't going to
kick in for a while we're facing you
know broken Global Supply chains that we
have to have to address do you think
that was going to answer the mail well
if you wanted someone to tell you a
bedtime story Michael Bennett really can
do it for me I can't even remember what
I was going to say but that is some
smooth baritone
let's talk ice cream yeah the symbolism
of a grown man holding an ice cream cone
is awful men should only lick ice cream
cones on vacation
licking an ice cream cone is a man is a
very personal thing it should not be
done in public yes
he's always on vacation so I guess he
can get away with it but you're really
exposed your tongue is out you're
licking something
[Music]
you can't do it if you have to have ice
cream
get it in a bowl yeah use a spoon for
the ice cream hold anything hold the
press conference patinate it hold a
meeting yeah
you just poured it down as gullet in a
bucket
but the the sight of of a man in a suit
the commander-in-chief licking an ice
cream cone and saying the economy is
strong as hell that will live in infamy
like Dukakis and the tank I was going to
say like mission accomplished Anna but
I'm sorry but it's almost worse than
mission accomplished because at the time
we thought the mission was accomplished
we know now the economy is not strong as
hell and he's still saying that so
that's going to run in ads forever
I'm going to give advice to Democrats on
how to talk about the economy I
shouldn't do it but I will
Joe's so simple he thinks when people
are adding jobs the economy is good and
people lose jobs the economy is bad it's
not that simple right now you can still
be adding jobs because we're coming out
of a pandemic but people can't afford
anything because of rates and high
prices so this is what he has to do he
has to say Yaya jobs yay I'm the best
and then he has to feel their pain on
all the other stuff they're getting
hammered on and then blame Wall Street
and the big Banks and big business for
price gouging because that's what
Democrats do that's how you do it mayor
Pete I expected more from him because
he's supposed to be the smart one this
is the McKinsey guy now at McKenzie they
don't teach you to say there's we did so
many good things I can't choose one you
just have to pick three things and
repeat repeat until the audience grasps
it well one of the things that Celia Rao
said was that don't worry there's going
to be tax credits to weatherize your
home yes even though eggs are up 30
exactly you're also going to get a
coffee maker you're going to get a tax
repaid on your coffee maker because I
don't know if you guys realize this my
coffee maker runs on fossil fuels so if
I get a new one like a different one
um is there one for like for like a
hundred dollars yes then I will get a
rebate look you know let's I gotta go
back with what Jesse was saying the
outrage about the ice cream there are 18
million people who are lactose
intolerant so when he comes up there and
he's with that ice cream basically what
I what we call that mic group of people
when we meet we call that ice cream face
like putting on your ice cream face it's
just absolutely disgusting that one
would do that doesn't he think about the
Americans at home who can't have ice
cream it's a microaggression it's a
microaggression and it's disgusting you
know and then he said the funny thing
about this and most people miss this the
economy is as strong as hell
what does that say about him that even
with a strong economy it's a disaster
it's like imagine if the economy was bad
how bad could this be but the fact is
it's it's it's it's it's its economy's
going gangbusters then it's on him that
everybody's suffering because you can't
blame it on the economy why do we have
inflation certain presidents are
expensive Trump was an expensive
president for the critics mental health
right it was like oh my God I have to
keep thinking it was just such an
expensive presidency Joy Behar weeping
Adam Kissinger crying all this mental
energy that was what they thought was
expensive this is expensive everyone
loses an average of 34k thirty four
thousand dollars in retirement is that
what it was we got a war we're talking
peace is worse than talking about nukes
the cost in human life to do defense at
all is amazing over six figures a year
over a hundred thousand plus you have
crime so you could argue that the Biden
Administration is the most expensive
presidency in history you're watching
Americans die by the tens of thousands
while he eats ice cream and offends me
uh and illegal immigration which drives
down wages also costing people things I
think the Republicans they could just
put up Billboards in all the major swing
states of how much money is being lost
in your 401k that's like probably their
best selling point and that's starting
to hit home hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else